for
uh I'm also uh the incoming assistant
professor in the University of walu uh
today I'm very happy to show some
interesting Direction in the uh database
Theory and algorithms uh which is The
Joint algorithms meet new constraints
scalability latency and
privacy okay uh in the relational
database the join is a fundamental
operator that can link the information
stored in different tables together uh
so given two tables uh with common
attributes uh The Joint operator will
find all pairs of tables with the same
value on their common attribute and if
we have more relations we can use the
joint operator to express more complex
analytical queries okay in this
relational Knowledge Graph each node is
an entity and each Edge is labeled with
the interaction between these two
entities and we can store the edges with
the same label in one relation and ask
join ques for example find all people
who like something in Thea Museum okay
use this three-way line joint this
problem in general is M hard if not
assuming the Quarry size as a constant
so people focus on the data complexity
of this problem and the traditional goal
of the research for the joint processing
is to find the most time efficient way
to report all the joint
results in the last 20 years the lead to
process and analyze big data has
invigorated this uh traditional research
area with a lot of new challenges for
example large volume data cannot be
stored and processed by a single machine
people have developed massive power
system such as map reduce and Spark for
data processing then how to design joint
algorithms that can skill to more than
hundreds or thousands of
machines we can also use a theoretical
model to capture the abstract uh the
architecture of those system so the
given uh input joint quiry and the
database distributed over the machines
uh the computation proc is in runs and
in each runs the servers can communicate
with each other and then perform some
local computation uh the complexity of
the algorithm in the mive parel
computation model are first measured by
the number of runs and then the load
which is the maximum size of message
received by any server in any round so
here the target is to design joint
algorithm that um uh achieve the optimal
tradeoff between the Run complexity and
the load complexity
the Second Challenge is that data is
generated at a very high speed the how
to deliver timy answers to the users um
similarly we can have a theoretical uh
model to capture the uh capture the
settings so given a joint query and the
database uh the target is to design a
data structure okay that can be updated
efficiently with the updates to the data
and also whenever the query answers is
uh is required from this user uh we can
enumerate the query answers from the
data structure with a delay guarantee so
the delay here can bound the waiting
time between consecutive answers okay um
and here the uh the theoretical Target
is to study the trade off between the
pre-processing time the update cost and
also the delay uh uh in an
enumeration uh the third challenge is
that uh data usually comes from multiple
resources and contain uh sensitive
information uh so people have PID a lot
of attention to the Privacy issue how to
evaluate a joint quiry without uh
leaking the information of the underline
database uh we can see the scenario that
even both the input data and the joint
answers are encrypt okay the adversary
can still learn something by observing
the behaviors of the joint algorithm so
what does the behavior mean so in the
sequential Ram model it could be the
sequence of R and right operators to the
main memory or in the massive parel
systems it could be the send and the
receive communication pattern of the
servers here the goal is to design joint
algorithm uh whose Behavior does not
lead to the distinguishability of the
input databases and if you want
different level of uh protection of the
Privacy you can also assume
differentially oblivious algorithm by uh
by the labor for the labor input
database
okay um so beyond the natural joint
there are many interesting joint related
problems I have worked on uh for example
the seminar join uh joint aggregate
queries uh sampling over joint a
temporal joint uh difference of joint
queries and generalizing uh synthetic
data site for the joint quiries okay uh
if you catch any interesting keyword uh
feel free to talk to me thank
you
any
question
okay we have one question yes about the
joints in fast data like streaming data
joints is that something that you yeah
for example we have some uh accounting
query on top of the joint results and we
want to releaseing synthtic data set for
example uh which is differentially
private uh and then still provide some
accuracy guarantee for answering
counting queries over the joint result
over the over the synthatic data thank
you